cbs news chief medical correspondent dr
john lapook
just got his first dose of the vaccine
and the cameras were there to record it
let us check in with him now john good
morning
good morning good morning vlad how are
you good i'm great uh first off
i want to ask you about the wave of
emotions that you and other
doctors nurses health care professionals
have described
in receiving the vaccine after serving
for so many months
on the front lines watching people
succumb to it and also watching people
survive how are you feeling
first of all i feel great i have a
little arm soreness uh and a little
tiny bit of swelling maybe the size of a
silver dollar but you're exactly right
i mean i was surprised by this wave of
emotion i got
really choked up and and teary and i
think it was not only
a relief that getting the vaccine but a
release i mean so many of us have been
under all this
pressure for so many months i mean for
me i was on the covered wards
back in april at nyu langone health
where i'm a professor of medicine
and of course my my clinical practice
and answering people's questions
uh and then of course doing this job as
medical correspondent but we all have
our own pressures and i think it's going
to be so important for us going forward
to understand
that we have an entire nation that's
been under
a ton of pressure there may be some
degree there will be some degree of ptsd
and i think about the kids and the aces
you know the adverse childhood
events an entire generation of kids who
had a year disruption
you know john a lot of people are
worried about the possible side effects
including my mom so
what are they
um you know they're they're mostly the
typical things for getting a shot so i
had a little arm soreness
there can be a headache you can have a
fever there can be a little bit of
swelling at the site you can have
fatigue but mostly it goes away in a
couple of days
dr lapook a lot of people say they've
been careful they're wearing
masks their social distancing and you
still have people end up with covid
what do you make of that how do you
explain that
you know jerica i love that you brought
that up because this
virus is astoundingly infectious
and one of the problems is that people
still don't have their arms around what
you need to do
i would say the very biggest
misconception that has led to problems
aside from not wearing a mask people
need to wear a mess come on um
is the the misconception that people
don't understand about the 2-14 day
incubation period so let's go over one
more time around the holiday seasons
because it's so important
yesterday a patient of mine said i got
covert tested yesterday which was yes
you know yesterday was wednesday
and i'm gonna go to a christmas party
over the weekend uh
is that okay and i said no not
necessarily because
with the two to 14 day incubation period
you could have been exposed she could
have been exposed a week ago
and tested negative yesterday but then
suddenly tested positive and become
infectious tomorrow the next day or the
next day so people have to understand
that 14-day quarantine
period is for a reason you can't just
fly to get a test
be negative fly to somebody else and
other part of the country or go to your
relatives or loved ones and think that
you're perfectly protected
and the other thing is that people need
to remember indoors
it was it was information that was
really did not end up being correct
that if you're indoors it's not just six
feet
anywhere in the room with somebody not
in your protective pod you've got
to wear a mask because think of
cigarette smoke imagine somebody 30 feet
away who's smoking a cigarette
and you're 30 feet away from them can
you smell the cigarette smoke if you can
which of course you can
then you can get infected by that virus
especially over time with it
accumulating
uh especially if there's not not enough
ventilation open the doors crack the
crack the windows and wear masks all
right dr donald pook thank you very much
we'll be right back